hey yes today I'm going to show you guys
how to get the mac OS 10 cursors working
in windows vista or windows XP I
provided a link in the description its
win matrix calm and this how we'll open
up in an internet browser here you can
see it here is the one matrix length I
showed you this and here are all the
persons though exactly like Miguel
attend and excited I want to download
them if it is right here the mackel is
ten jobs if the second opponent it will
bring up the second window where you can
download it for free you have to wait a
certain amount of time before the file
hosting actually comes up then it'll
instantly ask you if you want to install
it just select yes and soon enough when
the installer is done then you will have
all pls Hank cursors now you'll notice
mine not been applied yet so I'm going
to show you how to apply it what you
want to do is either in your rocket dock
or from your hands little image cut menu
open up the control panel and we're
going to double click on your mouse and
this will bring up a software that I
review you're the best with the
microsoft wireless and something else
however the school or pertaining to my
pal select pointers and look for mac OS
x click on it once and select apply and
you'll instantly have the macro
extension in windows vista so I don't
feel like this tutorial I hope you have
get the chance to you pls Hankerson I
really like it I'll use as my default
person from now on so I'm good luck with
that and have a subscribe